[Music]
what up guys welcome back
to off the record with two daddies and a
baby
and today we're going to talk about the
future of
boxing have you guys seen
that mayweather is gonna fight logan
paul
that shit's crazy how about the last
fight though which one
tyson roy jones fight like the
exhibition one right like i like
exhibition
someone that likes to watch fights i was
very unsatisfied from it
at the same time for someone that likes
the
kind of like the history of it i was
very it was very cool to see
two greats fight again but it felt like
glorified
sparring yeah it didn't feel like
seeing them go at it yeah i didn't sense
like anyone wanted to kill anyone plus
the commentators it made like it's
stupid
i love it it was so dope but it did make
it seem like a joke
oh yeah because usually like you know
commentators they have a balance
there's like color commentator which is
the guy with like the personality and
then there's usually
a a technical guy yeah but they only had
snoop so it was just all
jokes the whole time and there's no one
like breaking anything down i did see
this uh like article come out about the
rules that
jones and tyson agreed upon and it was
uh one of them since its exhibition
fight one of them is no knockouts yeah
so if someone gets knocked out
they're disqualified which also means
they'll probably never be allowed to do
an exhibition fight again so
it is already part of the rules they're
so old yeah that they can't knock each
other out
it was gonna be eight rounds which is
kind of like it's a weird because
if it's four and four it's for sure
gonna be a tie like they should just
make it an odd number like the ufc
mm-hmm you know the ufc
the three rounds or five rounds well
then i think i saw where it was saying
that
it was going to be no declared winner oh
i think i saw that too yes yeah
it sounds like a poster so then uh for
me i'm just like
it's weird because tyson's a knockout
artist yeah he's not a like a a points
guy
yeah you know so that's what i was just
like he can't do what he's good at yeah
jake has been surprising me though jake
paul yeah he actually did really good
you did good yeah
well like uh cause i went to his fight
in miami and then i saw the
just from like online from before like
uh the first fight he did
like he's actually been trying to train
with him and like uh like my roommates
are really good friends with him
so then you see like he's actually like
training properly
seriously which coming from their past
online and like who he is
i wouldn't have expected that and even
the way he's calling out these fighters
like he's the best
he called out mcgregor yeah and it's
like it's crazy
i get where it's coming from but it's
like it's very egotistical
yeah and i guess that's what's good for
numbers and [ __ ] but it does seem like a
kid trying to
like play with the adults yeah even
though he has a skill where he could do
some damage you know if he started out
like
actually taking it seriously we haven't
seen him fight a pro yet though
no so we don't know yeah yeah he's
fighting other people that are just like
him or like they just got into the sport
yeah
i mean if he fights a pro who knows
what's gonna happen but
it's there's one side of me that always
views him as a douchebag right like just
his persona seems very douchey
the way he calls people out is very
douchey but then there's the other side
of me that i kind of respect him as like
a guy that's able to put on events and
almost like in the promotion and
business realm
yeah because he knows how to create a
buzz yeah like once he put that out
like i think he told dana white like yo
send me any of your mma fighters in the
boxing ring i'll beat them all up
so he pretty much like shot uh called
that entire organization and from that
you got michael bisping coming out like
yo i'll fight you
dylan dennis said i'll fight you henry
cejudo said i'll fight you so like
his ability for him to make noise it's
pretty crazy
he's literally the like the biggest in
the fighting sports right now in terms
of
that you know it's like it's crazy
because then also it sucks but it's good
because
you see how business sided
the fighting corporations are yeah that
they're like
[ __ ] the regular fighters we're gonna do
this because we know this is gonna bring
way more money
even though it's making the sport a joke
that's what dana white was saying i
think someone asked dana like uh so how
do you feel about the sport of boxing
now and what he said he goes look at the
sport of boxing
tell me what the biggest fights are and
that's what the so i think to him he's
saying
boxing is dying which is why you need
novelty [ __ ]
yeah ufc you don't need any novelty
people want to know who
actually know who the best of the best
are yeah yeah but also i don't know i
think maybe just this day and age
like people just want to see crazy [ __ ]
yeah i don't know if boxing is truly
dying because they still have the
biggest paychecks
but people want to see crazy [ __ ] i
think
i think it's lost its um wow factor yeah
so like from my limited knowledge of the
evolution of boxing
i would say like maybe in the 90s with
the tysons and the
holyfields and the heavyweights and the
knockouts and
that and prior you had you know
guys that just wanted to like go
balls mode and then they became smarter
athletes
now like our generation is mayweather
right so that's what it evolved
up to is like i mean you do have your
knockout guys but it's like
to actually survive they're thinking so
long term
they're thinking like how can i survive
without ct
how can i become you know like there's
just so many of these factors
and then there's great technical
fighting but then the average person who
might just tune in to boxing
they'll be like why are you guys hugging
so much it's boring yeah
so like i think with ufc and all these
other
more wow factor fight sports when they
watch
boxing now it probably seems to um
like you don't get it it's like boring
well that's what the boxers when like
mma was getting big they were saying oh
it's just brutal animals like it's
not like there's no like style to it but
then it's like
there is you know there is a lot of
technical stuff but that's like the most
realistic form of fighting yeah it's the
only thing we have closest to the
gladiator fights
boxing it's like unless you're actually
a super fan of the sport and understand
the
technical side of it it's very boring
yeah we've seen guys jab each other just
winning by points because
yeah it's super technical yeah yeah and
i think because of that
um you know you can be the greatest
fighter but if people don't understand
the sport
they also can't enjoy it it's like power
lifting a straw man compared to
weightlifting
yeah so it's like weightlifting is the
stuff that you see on the olympics it's
the most technical like same thing with
boxing would be on the olympics
um but you won't see like mma or power
lifting on there because it's
kind of more brutal it just brute
strength just pick it up where
weightlifting is a lot of technique and
you don't know how much things weigh
and it's like i can deal with 600 pounds
but the world record for a clean is
uh like 400 or 500. so it's like
i can pick that up but it's so much more
to that but people just don't understand
that because
it's like oh he just cleaned 500 but i
deal with six or 700
i feel like i'm stronger that's true i
feel like olympics
the sports that make it in have claps
like this
except for basketball basketball i love
seeing like our nba team
go up against other countries and just
[ __ ] wreck the [ __ ] out of them
what's more exciting
winter or summer oh that's hard to say
but summer has a lot of
funny sports too yeah america gets oh i
mean the whole world but we get behind
like
our american athletes in like
high jump and swimming and [ __ ] that we
never would care about
that's true just for america to win yeah
i mean when tyson
was doing the olympics as a youngin that
[ __ ] was exciting
so his i think just his movements are
exciting you don't have to understand
boxing
but there's just guys back then that
moved a certain way that made people
excited yeah because he was like you
know
in the boxing olympics you wear headgear
yeah and that was knocking fools out
still
yeah you know and that's like you're
like what the [ __ ] this is so crazy
how's he knocking people with headgear i
wish i could like
hire tyson like knock me out at night
sometime
not cause we go to sleep yeah because
sometimes it's been hard like recently
yeah cause if you had an app then you
don't have to what's up
calm good thing this video is sponsored
by com
hell yeah we're excited to be partnered
with com because the app is designed to
help you ease stress
and get the best sleep of your life so
you don't have to hire someone to knock
you out end up getting cte
and brain trauma this is a very very
safe way
and when you relieve anxiety and improve
your sleep you feel better in
every part of your life and calm has a
whole library of programs one of my
favorites just the standard white noise
i don't hear any of the weird stuff that
goes on outside and it's very
very soothing and actually when it's too
quiet it's hard for me to sleep
but they have soundscapes guided
meditations over a hundred sleep stories
that's so nice narrated by soothing
voices like stephen fry
kelly rowland and laura dern over 85
million people around the world use calm
to take care of their minds and get
better sleep hey pretty
even put on your phone and you know when
you're on a plane you can probably fall
asleep better
and if you go to com.com off the record
you get a limited time offer of 40
off a calm premium subscription which is
almost half off
which includes hundreds of hours of
programming get the call map and
experience a transformation in the way
you sleep
for listeners of the show com is
offering a special limited time
promotion of
forty percent off a calm premium
subscription at com.com
off the record that's forty percent off
unlimited access to comms
entire library and new content is added
every week
get started today at com.com off the
record that's
calm.com off the record
dude another thing i just thought about
with the boxing
thing is i remember a couple years ago
they've been going
through controversy after controversy of
corruption
and scores like the last pack out fight
or the
la two last ones or whatever and then so
like people were losing
i guess faith in the sport or there was
just a lot of
issues right and then there was so much
talk about how boxing is dying and
whatever
um and then so now with
stuff like youtubers calling out other
people in the boxing ring
this is kind of bringing people that
didn't watch boxing
into it what's crazy is the mayweather
logan paul fight
because you that i want to see because
literally you have like
arguably the best boxer of all time with
a perfect record right 50 and
51-0 so perfect record
who's defeated all the greats oscar de
la hoya manny pacquiao all those guys
right here you have mcgregor and then
you have the
one of the biggest youtubers of all time
and you're like what the [ __ ] how the
[ __ ] did this happen
but also the thing is like if
logan beats him for some reason
the good thing he gets a lucky punch
it's gonna add to the pope paul family
legacy
yeah which is dope they're going to be
like the douchiest like
they could be good like especially logan
too like i think hopefully it's just
that well jake
i like jake i mean he seems like a
douche online
like and that's what you see that's what
joe rogan says jordan said he actually
met logan paul in person he's actually
really cool
i didn't meet i met logan uh just by
like
we're with the same group uh nothing
like really knowing but i was on the
the bus that we went with all the people
um and he was in
the bus in front to his fight and we sat
with everyone
so we came on the bus we're all talking
like talk to all of us just normal right
before the fight super nice
um yeah cause there's online persona and
then there's like who they are really
i mean like steve worked on the movie
that he wrote for him yeah
and he was he was saying that he's mad
hard working and he's chill
yeah so i'm just like i feel like he
could get the same buzz without being
that
douchebag like the way he calls people
out because you could call someone i'd
be like i'll [ __ ] up mcgregor i'll do
this without being like i'm the [ __ ]
greatest fighter of all time
obviously you're not you know you just
bought a youtuber um but the crazy thing
is like say that does happen say he
beats him
cause logan paul is also a big
[ __ ] who's
crazy athletic very athletic crazy
crazy wrestler he's actually trained for
this luckily it's a no knockout
i i actually want to see him in mma too
because of his wrestling
people people see them online jake's
like four inches taller than that jacob
yeah cause logan's even taller than jake
yeah well i think jake is
like six one six two really damn eight
boys i'm 5 10.
not that short but they're because the
guy that he fought
the basketball guy was is actually like
my height that kind of got knocked out
so bad dude
like the way boom his legs went
and then i see all the memes immediately
i'm like oh i feel so bad
the best people i saw was tyson uh
fighting uh roy jojo
and he's still on the floor
but the thing is like have you seen the
one where there's a guy who dressed up
as him in the supermarket and he's just
laying on the floor
no and the people walking by y'all wake
up he's just on the floor
that's so [ __ ] funny i'm like damn in
this day and age if you get [ __ ] up
that's the scary part yeah like the
whole world it's what michael michael
jordan was talking about he was like
kids like you know
what are you saying like oh it was jamie
foxx talking about him when he met him
yeah and he's like
kids only know you as like the cry face
they don't even know he's the best
basketball player of all time nobody
knows who nate robinson is if they're a
young kid that's a fan of jake paul
that's so sad so they're just gonna
clown him for the rest of his life
so it's it sucks like i couldn't do that
it's a knockout guy that's the knockout
guy yeah
i hope though that it's not exhibition
and like it's actually a fight fight
and see what happens that'd be pretty
cool like
like they go all out i don't think
they'll ever go all out they won't
i think both ways unless logan gets
lucky um
because i think jake is a way better
fighter than logan because he's probably
been training more he's been i think
he's been taking it way more serious
uh i'm sure logan has too i don't know
like exactly when are they gonna fight
well i think know how [ __ ] bald in
there
like when i watch jake's uh and logan
too
like their training videos jake he has
like a giant [ __ ] living room in his
mansion right
and he put a ring in the middle of his
mansion and i think
logan uh in his backyard he has so much
space because both of these schools
probably live in like 10 000 square foot
homes yeah he has a ring
in his backyard too so i'm like damn
these when you're like balling
you don't even need to go to a boxing
gym you just build one in your house
yeah it's crazy cause you're that famous
and [ __ ]
yeah and then like i i it's it's cool
i think for like say the sport of boxing
i'm like [ __ ] it i wouldn't want to see
that in mma
well i mean i would be cool because i
think they'll just be short-lived and
like when you actually see people really
trying to fight
um but imagine having someone because a
lot of these fighters and like the
people that i've met
uh because we met like arasonia or even
like say uh juju smith
they're huge in like video games they're
actual people so it's cool to see that
they can blend on both like social media
and
have an actual sport because say like
with powerlifting or sports like that we
do
people are so used to like oh you lift
heavy you're dumb you do this you can't
you can't be a doctor in this
there's a crazy boxing event in our
world too so uh you know thor from
game of thrones or uh the mountain so
he's a strong man
he's boxing eddie hall yeah is this
still happening yeah next year all right
so they're both two strong men it's
gonna be
like gorillas it's gonna be like a 400
pound guy fighting another 400 pound guy
and literally the two strongest people
that have pretty much ever lived
so it's 800 pounds in the ring and if
the ref is 200 that's a thousand pounds
in the ring
if the ref actually gets clipped he's
done he's dead
dang there's a lot of novelty fights
going on
this shit's crazy that's gonna be fun
would you guys ever do one i've been
trying
i've been telling you the thing is with
my teeth now what is it the price is
right is it for you the price has to be
right or
i'm like set it up i don't care just do
it
you're crazy the jujitsu fight yeah yeah
of the
role match competition obviously we have
so much respect for the sport and we
want to learn it but it was more of i
think
to clear up things online because
obviously there's like some people that
don't know who we are
it was more to show that you can't just
be a wrestler that's
trained and just kill it there's still
so much technicality that goes into it
yeah
um but we also did it like like we did
it
with the respect for the sport and we
signed up
into a tournament as nobodies and
respected the system
yeah like what the people are doing now
they're not going to
boxing tournaments and starting from the
bottom they're just straight up
i'm gonna imagine like you and me we
just call up the jiu jitsu federation
hey all the tournaments are sitting [ __ ]
that me and nadeem
super [ __ ] fight yeah you know that's
how they're doing it's way different it
sucks because it's like
they have to like they're legit people
but we're gonna go last
even though we're [ __ ] stuck yeah and
all those people have been trained their
whole lives for this
yeah doesn't mean compared to how much
attention we're bringing it and we're
bringing also bad attention yeah not us
but like that's how that's what they're
doing yeah but overall you're bringing
new people to the sport which is dope
yeah but that's what it sucks because
the purists are always going to fight
against
yeah growth and things like change like
that i
in the past i think i would have been
down but the more i research uh
ct and brain injury and things like that
i start to
think twice about um these kind of
sports
yeah even just with sparring and and
like medium sparring and stuff it's like
enough of these yeah and it can actually
[ __ ] you up yeah
so i'm starting to think now about how
um
that those concussions are just brain
like even they're not even concussions
but just
any type of head injury or just like
slight
you know what do you call it like like
any impact
yeah yeah you can even get it from like
slamming your head if you're
snowboarding
yeah i mean like eat it really bad you
can get ct from that too
yeah i know that's it sucks because all
the things that i enjoy
is high it's not like golf like it's all
high risk unless someone
golf's a balance i know right but it's
like most
sports that i'm into probably are high
risk sports
yeah that's why i started getting into
more jiu jitsu though because it is low
impact
yeah so you kind of get like the cool
aggression and then like you could like
compete but
like you know if me and the deemed spar
it's
chances are we're not gonna bump each
other into head versus like sparring
you know even when i spar with ron or
whatever and i get popped in the head
like
like for the next three hours i'm kind
of dizzy a little bit too right because
the goal of
any um striking sport is to give them a
head injury
yeah yeah so that that to me is like
[ __ ]
if we didn't have that and it was just
body shots probably
it's different yeah yeah but then like
for example like yeah you can get ct and
snowboarding
mountain biking but that's not the
intention of the sport
you try to avoid that and you try to
ride yeah right
versus like if we spar the goal is to
try to hit each other's heads sometimes
i mean if somebody called me out like
unless i'm doing like if i got into mma
boxing i would want to actually
actually train for it to eventually get
to like the ufc and stuff like that
that's why
don't because i know that's like a super
like your whole life has to change yeah
your whole life has been dedicated but
if somebody calls me out like they're
kind of
like a youtuber calls me out oh [ __ ]
yeah i'll do it yeah cause you're going
up against a youtuber
or why not i mean like even if it was
like i'm getting paid out too
like i'll do it for fun just like one
time a million dollars [ __ ]
ten thousand dollars [ __ ] it like but
it's like the
the whole side of it it's fun it's like
a challenge i like the competitions like
that yeah
but like thinking about it i do like
it it's it's a good balance between it's
like positive and negative on both sides
where it's like it's bringing negative
attention but also positive attention
for me yeah for me i was like before i
was like [ __ ] no because i love the
martial arts so much
it knows like a very sacred place like i
only want to do it the right way like
sign up for tournaments
but then i start seeing like how much
bank you can make
i started thinking about i used to be
honorable but now i'm selling out
maybe it could be a fun way so i think
for me it depends on the opponent and
then the paycheck because now i'm
viewing it as a fun way to make a lot of
money yeah
you know so if i could fight someone
and like i don't know and it becomes
more of a spectacle
because i think what it's trying to get
to is almost feels like you know back in
the day
like the colosseum with the gladiators
they're like what if the warrior
fights a monkey then what happens you
know so if it was like that
i don't know that could be that could be
cool i wish they did the russian uh
hunger games
what's that it was supposed to be a real
thing that they put these prisoners on
island
oh people were supposed to die or
something yeah
i i do applaud jake and logan i do think
that it's
they [ __ ] got the whole world
literally the whole they're
revolutionary yeah they're really
revolutionary that's true
that's that's what's crazy is like their
ability
to like revive a sport yeah that's
what's nuts
[Music]
you